وفق المعايير الميدانيه لا يمكن الحديث عن
توسع رقعه القتال المباشر جغرافيا بين
روسيا واوكرانيا لكن المعايير استراتيجيه
للحروب تفرض الحديث عن استهدافات باتت
اكثر توترا
قلب العاصمه موسكو دخل في مرمى المسيرات
الاوكرانيه ثلاثه استهدافات خلال اقل من
اسبوع واحد هذا ما اكدته وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه التي تحدثت عن استهداف منطقه
حيويه احد ابراج منطقه موسكو ست التجاريه
وعن ان وحداتها احبطت الهجوم واسقطت
المسيرات لكن اللافت هو ما لم تقله وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
وكاله تاس نقلت عما سمته مصدرا رفيع
المستوى في نظام الدفاع الجوي الروسي قوله
ان المسيرات التي اسقطتها انظمه الدفاع
اثناء محاولتها مهاجمه منشات في موسكو
وضواحيها انطلقت من الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
دون تحديد نقطه الانطلاق لكن نظريا فان
اقرب نقطه تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني
حاليا عن موسكو هي تشيرنيز في شمال البلاد
والتي تبعد قرابه 800 كم عن العاصمه
الروسيه كخط طيران مباشر هذا يعني ان
المسيرات قطعت هذه المسافه دون ان ترصد
كيف لم تقر باطلاق المسيرات لكن المستشار
في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل قال ان
الحربه تنتقل اخيرا الى الاراضي الروسيه
وبينما الصراع مستمر على السيطره على
البحر الاسود حيث تمتلك روسيا اليد العليا
نظرا لتفوقها العسكري الجوي والبحري قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها افشلت محاوله
اوكرانيه لاستهداف سفن مدنيه الروسيه في
البحر الاسود بزوارق مسيره كيف صارت لنفي
استهدافها اي سفن وقالت انها لم ولم تهاجم
اهدافا مدنيه في البحر